ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to "Cloud OnAir," live
webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Anita Kibunguchy.
And today we'll be talking
about how to accelerate insights
with external data sets
on Google Cloud Platform.
Really excited today
to be joined by Craig.
He's actually one of our data
providers from Weather Source
and he's part of the commercial
data set program here
at Google Cloud.
So Craig, introduce yourself.
CRAIG STELMACH:
Hello, everybody.
Thanks for attending
the webinar today.
My name is Craig
Stelmach and I'm
the senior vice president of
business development at Weather
Source.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Great.
Thanks, Craig.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So, let's get started.
So quickly on our agenda
today, the first thing
we'll start looking at is
the data analytics landscape.
Next, I will introduce the
public and commercial data set
programs, and then
next, I will give it
to Craig, who will talk about
the GCP data provider program
and then talk about
Weather Source.
He'll also go through a demo.
And then finally, we'll open
it up to a live audience Q&A.
So let's say I'm a
pharmaceutical company
and I'm actually thinking of
building some smart inhalers.
And the idea behind
this is that I
want to predict when
asthma triggers occur.
And the first thing I'm sure
you will start thinking about
is that these smart
inhalers definitely
need to have some
sensors embedded on them.
And part of these sensors,
as you can think about it,
will start collecting
a lot of patient data.
They'll be collecting a lot
of like frequency of attacks,
how much usage is being
done-- so medication
usage, patient vitals.
If you could think
about it, too,
if we were to do some type
of predictive analytics,
then we'll need some
form of weather data.
If we're looking at temperature,
allergens in the air.
And then of course, we'll
need some disease surveillance
data, region-specific
data, and then even just
a virus outbreak data.
The idea behind
this is that when
you're starting to think about
doing predictive analysis,
then you need all
types of different data
sets to be able to do
this type of analysis,
which makes a lot of sense.
So you will have
sources from internal,
which would be what's collected
by the smart inhalers, but then
at the same time,
you will need to tap
into all these other
plethora of data sets
that will be provided by
different sets of providers.
So we'll take a quick step back
and we'll look at the landscape
right now.
There is a lot of data
being produced right now.
And, according to
IDC, there will be
163 zettabytes of data by 2025.
For me, this is a lot of data.
I can't even imagine.
We're looking at a lot
of unstructured data
being introduced, a lot of
selfies that you can think
about, lots of cat videos.
How do we start to analyze that
and start to make sense out
of all that information?
And then on top of that, just
the idea of data complexities.
We're dealing with a lot of
legacy applications, data
silos, where finance has
their own different data sets,
and then you will have
supply chain having
their own different data sets.
But we know that
we need to start
merging that data
so we can actually
start providing insights and
actually being more productive.
Another thing is
regulatory environments.
There's been a lot of
talk within the last,
I want to say, year
just about GDPR
and how does that
affect the data being
collected by a lot of the
different organizations.
And then finally, just
when you think about it,
just the limited skills.
There's a lot of demand
for people who can actually
start to be able to do
these type of analysis
and we're just seeing a lot
of limited skill sets becoming
very hard to recruit.
And what's even more
interesting here
is that, this is a survey
that was done by Forrester.
This was actually done
just earlier this year.
And we're noticing
that enterprises
are very interested in expanding
their ability to source
external data.
I think enterprises
are realizing
the benefit of being able
to augment the existing data
sets with external data.
And so they know
there's a lot of value
and how do we now start bringing
that data to these enterprises
so that they can actually
start to get more out of this?
So now I'll introduce you to the
public and commercial data set
program.
But again, as you can imagine,
we'll take a quick step back.
On the left hand side, we're
looking at a traditional data
analytics platform.
In that type of platform,
we're looking at organization
spending, a lot of time doing
monitoring, performance tuning,
making sure that their
systems are reliable,
resource provisioning.
And then if you look at
one person doing all this,
then the amount of time left
to do analysis and insight
becomes so small.
However, when you look at
on the right hand side,
you have the serverless
data analytics model.
And this is part of the
Google Cloud Platform.
The idea here is
that we take away
all those different complexities
and we let your people focus
on the things that
they're good at,
which is analysis and insights.
And so, again, quick
step back, we'll
look at some of the
different products
that we're providing
as part of GCP.
We're providing a complete
foundation for data lifecycle,
all the way from
the point you're
ingesting data with products
like Cloud Pub/Sub and data
transfer service, and all
the way to advanced analytics
with Cloud ML Engine and then
things like Google Data Studio.
And then of course, we're
also providing the ability
to be able to orchestrate
all these things with Cloud
Composer, which is a
product that we've just
recently launched.
So again, complete foundation
for data lifecycle.
And the idea here
is that we would
like to have our customers
really focus again
on analysis and insights.
It's almost like, let us do
all the hard work for you.
So now we'll do a
quick introduction
on the public and
commercial data set program.
And the idea behind
these programs
is that we're looking
to provide access
to data sets hosted on
Google Cloud Platform.
And what makes these
two programs distinct
is that users,
customers, organizations
can access and analyze
structured and unstructured
data in the cloud without
a need to move data.
The idea here is that we've
already provided the data,
it's being hosted in
BigQuery, in this case,
and all you have to do
is pretty much come in
and access the data there.
The other thing we're
providing is the use
of familiar data
warehouse and analytics
software, things that you're
very, very familiar with.
Again, if you're a
BigQuery customer,
this should not be too
complicated for you.
It should feel
very, very similar.
And then finally, while
also providing a simple
and easy to use interface.
Again, I've mentioned data
can be created directly
from the BigQuery web UI.
The idea here is we
want to make this
as easy as possible
to be able to have you
start to create insights and
really get a lot of value
from data sets.
And so I'm sure you're
probably curious.
Those were sort of
like the similarities
between the two programs.
Now, what are the differences?
The first thing is that from
a public data set program
perspective, data is freely
hosted and accessible
to customers in GCP.
Again, we host the data for you.
All you have to do
is just come to GCP
and you're able to access it.
From a commercial
data set perspective,
data is hosted in GCP by data
providers, like Weather Source,
and standard GCP usage
charges may apply.
The second difference is that
for a public data set program,
users can actually
freely query up
to a terabyte of data per
month directly from the web UI.
Again, here,
honestly, it's free.
And then from a commercial
data set program,
users just have to
license the data set
from the data provider.
So in this case, if you are
interested in accessing weather
data, then all you
would have to do
is try to figure out how to
license that data, again,
from Weather Source.
And once you get
access, then you
would definitely just be able
to access that directly in BQ.
And then finally,
from public data
sets, what we're
seeing a lot of people
do is that it
provides a playground
for those new to big
data and data analysis.
Because again, the data is
public and it's also freely
hosted up to a terabyte
of data per month.
On the commercial data set
side, what we're doing is
we're providing
commercial data which
has been curated and
vetted for analysis.
So in this case, Weather
Source had made sure
that this data is ready
to be consumed by you,
and so this creates
a lot of value
for a lot of our customers.
And here are some examples
for the different types
of data sets we have posted.
On the left hand side,
this is a public data set,
so you can access things like
GitHub data, Medicare data, Dow
Jones data.
So it just depends on
what type of questions
you're looking to get answered.
And then on the commercial data
set side, as you can imagine,
Weather Source, of,
course, Remine, Xignite.
These are just a
few of the providers
that we have hosted right now.
And we're also seeing
customers getting answers
to a lot of important questions.
So if you're looking
to understand
how real estate affects
traffic and long term
investments in
infrastructure, then you
will probably want to access
HouseCanary data, which
you would be able to join
with your own data sets
to be able to answer
these type of questions.
And then, I'm sure you're
probably wondering, how
do you access these data sets?
And I think the one
place I would like
to send you to is Launcher.
So if you were just to go
to Google Cloud Launcher,
you should be able to
access these data sets.
And here's just a quick snapshot
of what that looks like.
And then, of course,
if you're looking
to get a little bit more
information about the programs,
then you could just go
directly on our website
under commercial data sets
and Google Cloud Platform.
You can also access the
public data sets as well very
similarly.
So again, just go
ahead and google it.
You should be able to find.
All right, so now I'll
welcome Craig to talk to us
a little about Weather Source.
CRAIG STELMACH:
Thank you, Anita.
As I mentioned earlier,
my name is Craig Stelmach.
I'm senior vice president
of business development
at Weather Source.
Weather Source is a
technology company.
And since 2004, we've been
providing weather data
and weather-based solutions
to a wide range of businesses
in almost every industry.
It's interesting to note
that weather is actually
the largest external swing
factor in the United States
economics.
And annually, it results
in over $500 billion
in economic loss and other
large, large influences
on business.
And in 2017, Hurricane Harvey,
Irma, and Maria actually
resulted in over $200
billion in economic loss
and there were
countless lives lost.
However, despite acknowledging
this and understanding
these numbers and the
impact of weather,
it amazes me every
day when I talk
to large companies and small
and mid-sized businesses that
do not use weather as part of
their overall weather business
intelligence strategy, or don't
even have a weather strategy.
And that's where
Weather Source comes in
and we're here to help.
Our weather data is
essentially statistically
consistent, homogeneous data
that is perfect for analytics.
And unlike other
data providers that
actually take airport station
data only and interpolate
or extend that data to
your location of interest,
Weather Source
approaches its data
in a markedly different way.
We actually start with
your location of interest
and then we stage up to 15
different inputs, including
satellite, radar, local sensors,
and a lot of mathematics
and statistics to essentially
create a hyper-local weather
station at your source
or at your location.
So that is truly hyper-local
to your location.
And we're the only
data provider that has
that granular of weather data.
And our data sets are
perfect for analysis
because they are statistically
consistent and homogeneous
across space and time.
And our two main data
sets are OnPoint Weather
which is essentially a continuum
of data from the year 2000,
hour by hour, day by day.
Sorry, let me move
the slide forward.
Actually, move it back, sorry.
OnPoint Weather is a continuum
of data from the year 2000
to present and with a forward
forecast view of up to 42 days.
OnPoint Climatology
is another data set,
and that is essentially
the statistics
of weather over time.
So that's going to offer
such valuable information
as to what is normal or average
weather for any location
at any point in time,
which would be your mean,
and what are your
departures from normal.
That's your standard deviations.
And many times we find
that most businesses
respond during those
departures from normal.
You know what
consumers are going
to do when it's 70
degrees out, but what
do they do when
it's 95 degrees out?
Those are the types
of insights that
can be gleaned from
OnPoint Climatology.
And because these data
sets are homogeneous,
they actually are perfect
for analysis and analytics.
Consumers are able to actually
create baselines of business,
asset, or consumer behavior.
And then once you
establish those baselines,
you can perform regressions
using the past weather
data set to create
scoring or rankings as
to how your business responds
during those departures
from normal.
And then using
forecast data, you
can create a predictive
model all within GCP and all
with using tools within GCP
to look forward and create
an actionable
business intelligence
and weather-based strategy.
So OnPoint Weather and
OnPoint Climatology
is available for
any lat-long point
or any
geographically-bounded areas,
such as zip or postal
code, and it is global.
And we're on every
landmass in the world
and extend up to
200 miles offshore.
Weather Source's
superlative engineering team
also has the resources
and capability
to assist with any modeling
or analytics project
and ensure that you're
obtaining the most
actionable and relevant business
intelligence from the use
of our global weather data.
All of our developers,
with the exception of one,
are also duly trained
meteorologists
and climatologists, which is of
great benefit to our end users.
We also offer free API
trial accounts, sample data,
proof of concept,
and we presently
have three sample
data sets in BigQuery
that are easy to access.
And that includes past weather
data, climatology data,
and forecast weather data.
And all of those are global.
We also, in addition,
offer turnkey solutions,
and an example is our Weather
Impact Ranking System,
WIRS for short,
which is essentially
a planning tool for weather's
impact on a business.
And WIRS essentially
allows companies
to monitor all of their assets
from a single pane of glass.
And through a notification
and an alert function,
can stay in constant
communication
with their customers,
staff, contractors,
or any relevant
business personnel
that are needed to make
an informed decision.
And the screen that
you're looking at here
is just a sample.
This particular customer was
concerned with various perils,
and the perils were
thunderstorms, wind, storm
surge.
And they had a
significant amount
of assets in the Houston area.
So what WIRS does from
this single pane of glass,
it allows you to plot all
of that business's locations
right through Google Maps
API so you're constantly
monitoring real-time weather
and what its impact is.
And then when that weather that
exceeds the ranking thresholds
that we establish through
using our statistically
consistent data sets,
you're able to then take
appropriate action.
And some examples of
appropriate action
are, I know that I have a
venue with outdoor seating.
If I see hail
present itself, I'm
probably not going to
have staff coming in
to work the outdoor seating
area because I'm not
going to have customers using
that area of my business.
So it's a great tool.
So we have the soup to nuts,
which is, we have the data,
we have the middle, which
is the analytics ability
to assist with the
modeling project,
and then we have full-blown
solutions that actually ingest
your data and perform
all the analysis for you
and monitor actively
and in real-time.
And some industries
that Anita and I
talked about that could leverage
weather data are retail.
Obviously, with all things
Amazon and the change
in our landscape from brick
and mortar to e-commerce
is essentially
resulting in retailers
scrambling to find ways to bring
customers into their locations.
Well, weather's one of the
largest influencers on when
customers go purchase things.
And there's other ways, like
not only footfall traffic,
but it's also seasonal and
non-seasonal product sales--
knowing when to
mark products down.
If you mark products
down according
to a pre-determined
date, you might end up
with an unseasonably warm
fall and people might still
be paying full price or willing
to pay full price for that fall
gear prior to
transitioning into winter.
So we're able to
help retailers use
our data to quantify
the impact of weather
on their consumers behavior.
Logistics and transportation.
Obviously logistics
professionals, their number one
concern is delivery of goods
from point A to point B,
and weather is
one of the largest
disruptors of that transit.
So our weather data allows
logistics professionals
to plan for that
weather proactively
and create steps or take
appropriate business response
to mitigate disruptions
and, in many cases,
prevent disruptions.
Travel and hospitality
is another great one.
It's not only when
customers are expected
to come to your
facility, but it's
when not to expect customers
coming to your facility.
We recently engaged with
a large sporting venue
that was concerned about
concession sales and employees
as related to
tickets conversions.
So what we did was we
analyzed weather patterns
to find when customers were
not purchasing tickets or not
showing up to the
venue, and then we
created a predictive model
so that when these weather
events presented
themselves, they
could have less staff or
less concessions available.
And ultimately,
saving this end user
a considerable amount of money.
So there's all kinds
of ways that weather
plays a very important
role in business
pretty much across
all businesses.
Pretty much every business
has weather sensitivities.
And as I said
earlier, it's amazing
that people aren't leveraging
weather data within the GCP
to create models to take
advantage and proactively
prepare for these type
of weather disruptions.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: And I
think one of the other things
you had mentioned, Craig, was
the idea that how do you maybe
start to use this
weather data but also
so that you could
understand the things that
aren't impacted by it.
How do you remove that
within your analysis,
or see the impact
of other things
that are not being affected
by weather so you're
incorporating that data?
CRAIG STELMACH: Absolutely.
So that is another
method that generally,
as we're creating
our models and going
through the analysis
with our customers
in the scoping,
what we generally do
is de-weatherize the situation.
So we actually use weather to
find out whether it's actually
a variable and impactful
for that particular business
parameter.
If we identify that,
then what we do
is we plan against that weather
versus if we do find that they
have weather
sensitivities, then we
apply a predictive model
that's based on the weather.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Absolutely.
Great.
CRAIG STELMACH: OK, so now
I'm going to do a demo.
The objective of my
demo is basically
to show how weather data can
play a role in forecasting
consumer search
behavior and how we're
able to create better forecast
models using machine learning.
All of this is being done in
the Google Cloud Platform.
And I'm a sales
guy, so you'll see
how easy it is and I'm hoping to
produce some meaningful results
for you.
And another significant
overarching message
is how easy it is to use
BigQuery and actually pull
large data sets.
Our data sets in BigQuery
are petabyte-scale databases
and it's easy to pull data
from disparate sets of data,
join them, and then
perform modeling with them.
And for this particular demo--
I have to go to my
screen, one sec, please.
So now I'm bringing up
my Google Cloud Platform.
I've already
preloaded some things
so you don't have to be
bored with me loading things.
I launched this with
Google Cloud Launcher
and I'm right now in the
Google Cloud Platform.
And I'm using Google
Trends search data
and I used three
weather-sensitive search terms.
And I used air conditioners,
flu, and snow tires.
And I use three weather values,
and those weather values
were feels like temperature,
precipitation, and snowfall.
That was over the
period of seven years,
so with seven years of
data both on Google Trends
and from my past weather data.
And I'm using the entire
state of Massachusetts
where I'm based as my DMA,
or Designated Market Area.
So in advance of this demo,
I downloaded my Google Trends
data into CSV files and I
upload it into BigQuery.
And so now I launched my
Google Compute instance.
And what you're
looking at now is
essentially I'm going to
open my Datalab instance.
So very simply I
activate my Cloud Shell,
which is going to give
me my command prompt.
And this was the delay I'm
talking about, so sorry.
Sorry, I have to start
my instance first.
Like I said, I'm not
the technical person,
so my technical people
set this up for me.
Still starting.
And we've created, like I said,
my Datalab instance prior.
And Datalab is actually a
full lifecycle workbench
that allows you to analyze,
visualize, and manipulate data,
including creating learning
models, all within GCP.
So very, very
robust application.
So now it's going to prompt
me to change my port.
So I'm waiting for my
Datalab instance to load.
Sorry, Anita.
But I just wanted to show
everybody how easy it is
and how this is all within
the Google ecosystem.
So open my web preview,
change my port to 8081,
and now it's going to open
a new window, which is going
to be my Datalab instance.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Maybe you
can tell people what to expect?
CRAIG STELMACH: So now it's
opening up my Jupyter Notebook.
And Jupyter is essentially
also found within the GCP.
And Jupyter is an integrated
development environment
that's fully accessible
within the GCP
and allows me to create
Python-type scripts that
are easy to run and use.
And essentially I'm running all
my code also using Google Cloud
Datalab.
Now, first step, is going to
be I'm importing my libraries.
And I'm using Python pandas
for my data manipulation,
matplotlib for my
data visualization,
and scikit-learn for
my machine learning.
Again, all of these are found
within Google Cloud Platform
and accessible within
Google Cloud Datalab.
So very simply, I
hit Shift and Enter
and it's going to run that.
And again, very low latency.
I am on a guest
network right now.
Now I'm going to import my
google trend in weather data
from BigQuery and I'm
going to join the data.
And I'm doing this by
running a simple join
using the date in my disparate
tables within BigQuery.
So again, being able to pull
this data easily and seamlessly
all within BigQuery.
Now I'm going to create my
training and testing data set.
And for this demo, I used
a traditional machine
learning approach where
I divided the data
80% from my training,
20% from my testing.
Shift and Enter,
very, very simple.
Even a sales guy can follow it.
So now I'm going to create a
simple machine learning model
and I'm using a random
force regression.
So that is a common machine
learning regression approach.
And if you remember,
my target variables
are flu, air conditioner,
and snow tires,
and my three weather parameters
are feel like temperature,
snowfall, and precipitation.
So again, you can see
how quickly this is.
And again, these are
machine learning models
and it's performing
literally in seconds.
So now I'm going to create my
random force regressor that's
performing my analysis.
Now I will fit my model
with the training data.
And once the model
is trained, it's
ready to use for
predictive analytics.
And so now I will actually
run my fitted model
on my test data.
And if you recall, I reserved
20% of my data for the testing.
And now all of my modeling
and testing is complete
and my entire model
has been trained
and I'm ready for
my visualizations.
So again, seamlessly, all
doing this within the Datalab.
So I essentially created a
model, I queried BigQuery,
I joined the data,
I ran it through,
created a predictive model,
and now I'm visualizing it.
So as you can see, what
you're looking at here
is the google trend and the
predicted value is the green,
and the blue is the
actual, true Google data.
So as you can see, even
with this relatively simple
exercise, you see very,
very strong correlations
between obviously consumer
search behavior and weather.
And although, obviously, we're
using weather sensitive terms,
as Anita mentioned
earlier, this could
be used for non-weather
sensitive terms
to kind of de-weatherize
and find out
if there is any impact.
And that could be
something of removing
that variable of weather.
And my google with
air conditioning
is even more telling.
And what's really
significant about this slide
is the spikes because
this is showing
how strong of an
influence weather
has on consumer search
behavior and ultimately
the consumer purchasing.
And then the last model
that I have to visualize
is my snow tire example.
And as you can see, this is
even more so with snow tires.
And it's interesting--
we can actually tell you
that 80 plus percent
of your snow tires
are sold on the first
instance of a snow forecast,
and then there's
a dampening effect
that occurs over the
subsequent three months.
So in the fourth month, you're
really selling less than 2%
of your snow tires.
But again, I'm not showing
that with this demo.
What I'm showing with
this particular slide
is just the strong correlations.
And clearly, you
can see how easy
it is to create a
machine learning model
using weather within
Google Cloud Platform
and using BigQuery.
And these strong
correlations really
clearly show the influence
of weather on consumer search
behavior.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Absolutely.
And I think for some
of these organizations
it starts to provide you
with a way to figure out
when to spend money.
If you're looking at
when do you actually
amp up things like advertising
and when do you ask for funds,
when do you not.
I think if you know that
the first couple of months
is when snow tires
will be sold most,
then that's probably
when you should actually
be increasing advertising.
Is that right?
CRAIG STELMACH: Exactly.
And back to your asthma
example, another great example
with asthma is because with
the climatology data having
the normal or
average weather data,
you're able to
look for anomalies.
So when the forecast
shows that it
is an anomaly over what is
true or average or normal
weather, a company that
sells asthma medications,
when they understand
what triggers
asthma-- precipitation,
humidity, pollen,
things like that.
If they recognize that
they have an anomaly,
they can move into a region
and start advertising
in advance of the competition.
So understanding when
consumers are going to buy
allows you to get the leg
up and essentially deploy
marketing or other
resources in that region
to make sure you have
a competitive advantage
over your competition.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Absolutely.
And if you think
about it, too, for
that pharmaceutical company,
what's even more interesting
is that now they
can actually start
to provide patient care
before things happen,
because you have good predictive
models of when things like
allergens, things like humidity,
things like temperature,
and how those are impacting
somebody who has asthma.
And can you now actually start
to provide patient care before
even those things happen?
And that becomes really powerful
for organization or even
for a company.
[INAUDIBLE]
CRAIG STELMACH: Absolutely.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Thank
you so much, Craig.
I think that was
very eye-opening.
I think the biggest
takeaway here
is the idea that we realize
that a lot of organizations
are now going to
be able to source
every single type of data set
they need to do their analysis.
And this is where things like
public and commercial data
sets programs hosted on GCP
become very, very powerful.
Again, just to
quickly summarize,
data is available immediately,
so in a public data set
scenario, that's immediately.
For commercial
data sets, as soon
as you finish doing the
licensing with a data provider,
then you can access data
directly within GCP.
Secondly, data is ready for
analysis with familiar cloud
products.
Again, I think Craig has
done a great job showcasing
some of those products
like the BigQuery UI.
I think we've talked a
little bit about Datalab,
but these are products that
you're very familiar with
and they're the
same ones you'll be
using to access the public
and commercial data sets.
And then, finally,
I think to reiterate
here is the idea of getting
more value from a growing data
ecosystem.
I think one of the
things we talked about
is that there is increasing
plethora of data out there,
but how do we start
helping our customers be
able to access the
data when they want it
and make that process easier?
I think one of the things
I keep hearing about is
this idea of democratizing
data and insights,
and this is what
this program does.
So again, thank
you for joining us.
Stay tuned for live Q&A. We'll
be back in less than a minute.
Welcome back to
the live audience
Q&A. So the first question
we got from the audience
is how much does it
cost to build out
the model you presented?
Craig?
CRAIG STELMACH:
Sure, so the cost
to build out that model
would be relatively small.
Generally, when we engage
in an analytics project,
we take a look at what
the end user is looking
for with respect to
output, and then we
back in essentially
time and materials.
So for example,
a model like this
would be several
thousand dollars,
but they can go all the way up
to-- if a business has 10,000
SKUs and they want
regressions performed
against each one of
those SKUs, you're
looking at a
different price point.
But our data is
extremely competitive.
And, as you know,
Google Cloud Platform
operates on a
consumption-based model,
so you're only paying
for what you use.
And then with our data, we
price by essentially location,
so it's really how many
locations and again,
for an analysis like that,
how many products you're
talking about and what is
the end user attempting
to accomplish.
But we are very,
very cost competitive
and we do not lose
against price.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Good to know.
OK, another question
for you, Craig.
So clarify what Cloud Datalab
is and what are its benefits.
I think there are a
lot of our customers
who are maybe not too
familiar with that product.
CRAIG STELMACH: Sure, so Cloud
Datalab is a full lifecycle
workbench that
essentially allows
you to take data, analyze
it, transform it, manipulate
it, model, including creation
of machine learning models,
and visualize all within
Google Cloud Platform.
So you're never having
to leave one ecosystem
to go into another.
Makes it very, very easy.
All of your work is saved there,
you can share and collaborate
across your entire business.
You can share those
visualizations to other people.
So it's just a great program
to essentially do everything,
but that's a very small
piece, as you know,
of Google Cloud Compute.
But it is a very, very
robust environment.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Great.
OK, so, how is GCP different
than other business
intelligence platforms?
And I think the first thing
that I would say is this idea
of providing to our customers
an end-to-end data lifecycle
management--
the idea that we
have products that
will help you ingest the data,
store the data, all the way
to start doing things
like predictive analytics.
And so you're not having to move
your data somewhere else, all
that is stored within
BigQuery, and you're
able to do this end-to-end
lifecycle of data management.
That's one big one.
I think that the next
big one is this idea
that we would like
our customers to focus
on analysis and insights.
So we take away
all the complexity
of performance tuning,
resource provisioning.
I think I've shown a little bit
of that a little bit earlier,
but the idea is we would like to
make this data analysis as easy
and as seamless as possible
for a lot of our customers.
Last question is how
easy is it to get started
doing predictive analytics?
What do you think, Craig?
CRAIG STELMACH: Well, it's
not very easy, obviously.
And it's not very easy to
actually work with weather data
because there's a lot of
nuances with weather data.
So analytics is hard.
Predictive analytics is hard.
Adding weather data adds
a level of complexity.
But again, Weather Source is
in the Google Cloud Platform
resources.
There's a ton of resources
available to help
you get started, and
so Weather Source
has the capabilities
to help you get
moving on any type of
predictive analytic project,
as do the support reps
for Google Cloud Platform.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Great.
Thank you so much for watching.
Please tune in next Tuesday
for the next "Cloud OnAir."